and start with that breaking news out of
russia we're getting reports that
opposition politician alexia navalny
is in a coma in a siberian hospital with
suspected poisoning
he was returning to moscow when he fell
ill during the flight
his plane made an emergency landing in
the city of omsk
the valencia spokeswoman says that he's
now in intensive care
that is on a ventilator journalist
alexandra steinovich godfor
is on the line now via skype from
moscow alexander what do we know of what
happened
so adrian uh basically uh he fell
sick almost immediately after boarding
that plane
in siberian town of tomsk eyewitnesses
say that he was
screaming and then he lost his
consciousness in the toilet after which
uh the plane made emergency landing in
olmsch where he was urgently
hospitalized according to his
press secretary kirayamosh he had
nothing but tea in one of the cafes
airport
that morning so she is saying that they
suspect that he's been actually
poisoned doctors of this hospital are
saying that his condition is
rather serious that they did perform
tests and they will
present results though they did not
specify when
his spokeswoman says that all of a
sudden these doctors are not very
cooperative they did call the police
which is now taking protocols in the
hospital
itself the said cafe in which navalny
had this
last t before boarding the plane
promised to have their own
investigation of what actually happened
to of course their their abilities at
this point
what we know is that he is in a coma in
a very serious
condition and they're waiting results
with a suspicion
of some sort of poisoning if
it is found that he has indeed been
poisoned this won't be the first time
will it
no it wouldn't be the first time neither
for navalny nor for some
other public figures that were critical
of uh
putin and uh kremlin navalny has been
suspected poisoned last summer almost a
year to it now
when he was in custody of moscow police
he was
in prison for allegedly organizing mass
protests in
moscow then he was also hospitalized
tests were performed
and then the doctors said that it's some
sort of an allergy but it was
never uh presented to what if it was an
allergy
what it was or if it was a poisoning
what sort of a poison it was he was also
attacked
two years ago in 2000 well three years
ago in 2017
antiseptic green dye has been thrown
into his face which
damaged his eye and he's been treated
for that for another long
period of time when it comes to other
politicians there are
uh document poisonings in london of
um uh grienko and then we had
the skripal case also prominent russian
journalist was once poisoned
exactly in a plane was without conscious
for days on end
alexandra many thanks indeed good to
talk to you uh derek mcdougall
is head of europe and principal russia
analyst at varus maplecroft a global
risk consultancy he joins us now
uh from london uh dara what are your
thoughts on on what
may or may not have happened to navalny
uh well it's it's very difficult to
paint a full picture of what has
happened
um at the moment given um
how quickly these events have happened
and equally it's important to remember
that while vladimir putin may try to
present the image of a unified russian
government under his command
there is an old russian saying that the
kremlin has many towers
we have seen in the past most recently
in 2015 with the assassination of
barresti himself
that sometimes other actors will take
matters into their own hands without
kremlin approval
certainly at the moment russia is
dealing with
several different situations the protest
in belarus
the potential negotiation of new nuclear
treaty with the u.s
and it's questionable as to whether or
not this is an opportune time from the
kremlin's perspective
um to to launch uh a
an operation of this kind uh on the
other hand we are seeing rising protest
sentiment in russia
uh and most recently we've seen with the
dismissal of
governor forgot in uh havarosk uh which
has
brought tens of thousands of people out
into the streets that you know the
the kremlin is worried about internal
stability as well so
this may be uh a signal
um from moscow to the broader opposition
that the gloves are coming off if you
will
uh but equally at this point it could be
any number of actors
uh navalny's uh fund uh foundation
against corruption fbk
has ruffled a lot of feathers both at
the national level and at the regional
level
um and it could be that uh that somebody
in uh
siberia decided to to take matters into
their own hands at this point without
kremlin approval
or even direction yeah so uh so yeah
this is a developing story
you're saying then that if there has
been an attempt
on the valni's life it it's highly
unlikely to have been
officially planned or sanctioned by the
kremlin
i wouldn't want to make a judgment on
that uh
on whether or not this has the kremlin's
blessing um
at this point there just isn't enough
information
at this point to make that call um what
i would say is that there's
a number of ways that blessing might
have come uh not necessarily directly
from putin but from another senior
official who
who might have calculated that it was
better to to act and ask for forgiveness
rather than to ask for permission on
this point
uh but equally um you know in the past
the kremlin has found that it can manage
navalny
um through occasional arrests when
needed uh
through denying him access to the media
and that he's an irritant
essentially to them that would you know
the cost of arresting him or killing him
or doing something
um extremely uh serious to him
uh such as what we've seen now uh would
outweigh the benefits
now the two possibilities here are
either that that calculation has changed
given the greater degree of unrest we've
seen both in russia
and again in belarus and that the the
kremlin is deciding that
uh now the repression needs to be
stepped up um or that somebody
lowered down the ranks was uh annoyed by
something that navalny did
again maybe uh exposing the corruption
of
some particular local or regional
official
and decided to take matters into their
own hands uh
but you know this is literally um
this happened in the last couple of
hours as far as i can see so
really we can't say with any certainty
um
why this happened or or who directed it
at this point
you say that the kremlin views navalny
to a certain extent as
an irritant to what extent though is he
a useful irritant as far as the kremlin
is concerned in that
to give some uh image of a
of democracy to project some image that
there is
that people do have a choice and that
they do need someone like navalny to
oppose the kremlin don't they
to an extent though it's important to
note that navalny has been
fairly ruthlessly kept off the ballot um
except in one or two occasions so you
know the the kind of whether or not
uh the role of kind of a a false choice
is more played by parties like the ldpr
and the communist party uh the so-called
systemic opposition
who provide organized political
opposition to the kremlin
but without opposition uh the bigger
role for navalny would be through
his fund against corruption fbk which
has come up with a surprising amount of
information
on the illicit activities of a number of
senior officials
which suggests that he does have some
contacts within the security services or
other
um agencies of the state who use him as
a means of kind of
laundering information about their
enemies uh and conducting
internal political battles of this type
um equally there is
a subset of the the administrative elite
if you want which knows that
um there may come a time in the future
when uh there is a political transition
in russia
uh there is an economic transition in
russia and that navalny may be a part of
that
um and so they realized that as as one
of the few
genuinely independent political actors
in the country they need to to maintain
some sort of relationship with him
um or at least keep lines of
communications open
that wouldn't rule out a poisoning of
this kind uh of course because you can
still communicate with somebody and then
decide that
um it's time to get rid of them um but i
i would say you're
you're reasonably on the mark there and
that having him around
uh does bring some benefits to the
kremlin um even if
on the balance i'd say they find him an
irritant more than
a useful tool good to talk to you dara
many thanks indeed dara mctill there in
london
thank you